[Music]
so one of the fundamental goals in sport
nutrition actually is this concept of
practicing your risk their strategy and
training and that's important for a
number of reasons really I mean we know
for forty years that high carbohydrate
improves exercise performance but
actually what we have to do is to tree
in the gut to be able to digest and
absorb that carbohydrate and then of
course we have to tree in the muscles to
be able to use that carbohydrate
efficiently and so if you don't practice
that realistic strategy in training then
you could turn up on race day not having
a muscle that's ready to use that
carbohydrate and of course we need that
to hit all performance goals so one of
the real cornerstones of sport nutrition
practices actually is the concept of
carbohydrate loading and that practice
was first developed in the late 1960s
and it's primarily all about consuming
the correct type and the correct
quantity of carbohydrate the day before
the event itself and that's really to
load up on muscle glycogen stores
because of course we know that muscle
glycogen is the predominant energy
source for marathon running so if you
don't fuel correctly for the Marton by
loading up the day before the event then
you're not really giving yourself the
best chance to perform there was a study
done many years ago looking at the
carbohydrate loading practices or people
undertaking the London Marathon and the
textbook guidelines is around 10 grams
per kilo and these athletes were only
really consuming 5 grams per kilo so
they were nowhere near hitting their
carbohydrate targets and it's really
higher glycemic types of carbohydrate
because we know that they actually store
glycogen in the muscle well I think
really you should be sticking to
world-class basics when it comes to
carbohydrate fueling and that's just
classic breakfast cereals past those
rice breads and so on energy bars and
sports drinks and if you get into the
practice of of consuming food every
three hours or so
hitting those carbohydrate argit's then
you'll give yourself the best chance to
turn up on race day itself with the
muscle and liver that's fully loaded
with glycogen ready to perform when it
comes to fueling during the marathon
itself then of course we know that we
need to minty and high carbohydrate
availability to top up your glycogen
stores and really the the magic number
is about 60 grams per hour and it's
really athlete dependent you can get
from fluids you can get that from gels
what I would say is that you should
probably treat your hydration goals and
your fuelling goals with two separate
strategies actually and my preference
would be to treat your fueling goals
rely upon gels we know that the science
and sport gels are isotonic they're very
well tolerated they're easy to digest
and absorb and kind of then just sort of
drink to thirst and usually when you
drink to thirst most people consume
around 500 milliliters per hour but the
real nice thing about that is you've
treated both hydration and fueling
separately you can practice your fueling
strategy in training you turn up on race
day everything's planned and you know
how you're gonna perform hopefully when
it comes to recovery there's three
simple things really it's about getting
food in the correct time
it's about getting food in at the
correct quantity and last but not least
is the correct and type of food from a
carbohydrate perspective then the magic
number is about 1.2 grams per kilogram
body mass so for instance a 75 kilo
runner would need around 90 grams but
actually the timing is really critical
and the muscle is most sensitive to
storing carbohydrate within 30 to 60
minutes post exercise so it's kind of
crucial that you really practice and
plan for that man that carbohydrate
refueling event really so I'd have
something and you kept by really ready
to go of course we also need protein
because protein promotes muscle repair
and muscle rebuild so if you get the two
main goals of carbohydrate availability
for replenishing energy stores protein
for recovery and then of course fluids
for rehydration
you